[Musik]
sie alle kennen diese merkel gipfel in
denen über unser aller corona alltag
entschieden wird über krankenhäuser über
altenheime über schulen am ende über
millionen jobs und wenn man so will
sogar über leben und tod und er ist
immer mit dabei thüringens linker
ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
doch während dieser wichtigen gipfel
spielt er auch gerne handyspiele kelly
crash das hat ramelow jetzt ganz offen
ausgeplaudert offenbar war das cool
findet wir finden das gar nicht cool
sondern diskutieren gleich ob so ein
double ministerpräsident wirklich der
richtige ist um ein solch wichtigen
entscheidungen beteiligt zu sein
tränengas randale feuer krawalle in den
niederlanden weil die menschen dort die
strengeren corona regel nicht mehr
aushalten sie für quatsch halten oder
beides und wir deutschen wir bemühen uns
doch manch einem geht in dieser krise
auch die kraft aus kann hier so etwas
passieren wie bei unseren nachbarn
ich hoffe es nicht aber es ist grund
genug nach der stimmung in locktow und
deutschland zu fragen und genau das
wollen wir hier in dieser sendung machen
und damit herzlich willkommen bei den
bild live - am abend mein name ist
patricia platin und mein name ist
teilweise
[Musik]
schön dass ihr wieder da seid ich bin
der wohnung und ich wollte etwas
verraten
ich beschäftige mich manchmal mit
videogames und mein top video game ist
canon rasch wenn ich zeit habe dann sei
2011 bei candy krass ich bin dabei level
den här nehmen und noch einmal
das bisschen kriegen oder noch ist das
ein lässiger politiker ein cooler
ministerpräsident thüringens linke
landeschef bodo ramelow will sich
offenbar selbst so sehen denn mit diesem
video hat er zuletzt wahlkampf gemacht
in seinem land bis hierhin eigentlich
kein problem aber jetzt hat ramelow auch
noch ausgeplaudert dass er nicht nur im
wahlkampf total gerne candy crash
dadurch sondern eben auch dann wenn
gerade corona gipfel läuft mit der
kanzlerin also wenn über unser aller
corona alltag entschieden wird wenn es
um milliarden jobs geht um krankenhäuser
und altenheime um geschlossene oder
offene schuhe in und so weiter und so
fort auch dann greift er ganz gern zum
handy und zockt und daddelt dazu kommt
jetzt auch noch dass wir die zahlen ja
ganz gut kennen die aus thüringen kommen
denn thüringen ist ziemlich weit hinten
dran bei den corona zahlen und auch beim
im tempo ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
dadurch vor sich hin während die
kanzlerin und alle anderen länderchefs
darüber streiten wie deutschland durch
die größte krise seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg kommen soll
candy crash mitten in den wichtigen
beratungen über die richtigen corona
maßnahmen verraten hat dass der linke
politiker ramelow am wochenende selbst
bei einer diskussion auf der neuen live
talk app clubhouse das spielen sei für
ihn eine entspannungsmethode da drin
während gerade über den lockdown beraten
wird der für millionen deutsche zur
existenzfrage geworden ist wenn ich
sowas lese und was der ramelow da
gemacht hat ich als gastronom der schon
seit november gucken muss wir irgendwie
zu rande kommt durch straßenverkauf oder
irgendwelche flyer die man macht man
investiert geld und so weiter und er
stellt sich ihnen beziehungsweise setzte
hin und spielt bei jedem einer wichtigen
konferenz auf seinem handy rum da war
ich stocksauer
sowas darf es nicht geben und so
einander gehört gleich abgesetzt also
der sollte zurücktreten wenn ich mich so
verhalten wird in meinem job
da würde ich wahrscheinlich rausfliegen
ich finde seine absolute frechheit und
ein schlag ins gesicht
zum einen rettungsdienstler und zum
anderen auch als privatmensch der sich
gedanken darüber macht ob seine kinder
gesund bleiben oder nicht unser land
das nackte überleben die menschen
kämpfen in den altenheimen ums nackte
überleben politiker die sich hier in den
vordergrund spielen und meinen die
ultimative lösung zu haben spielen candy
crash sager das ist eines politikers und
ministerpräsidenten unwürdig candy crash
dafür brennt bodo ramelow schon länger
2009 10 veröffentlicht die linke
thüringen dieses video schnelligkeit hat
dann seit 2011 bei candy crash ich bin
dabei 4398 und nun den er nehmen besser
als youtube könne er politik für alle
menschen in thüringen plakatiert der
clip nach den spielszenen
doch fakt ist thüringen macht in der
korona krise bisher keine gute figur
hildburghausen wurde zum absoluten
corona hotspot und geriet in die
schlagzeilen mit besonders
rücksichtslosen demonstranten rahmenlos
bundesland gehört zu den krisen
bundesländern hat mit 204 infektionen
pro 100.000 einwohner derzeit den
höchsten wert und ist somit schlusslicht
die zahl der toten lag in thüringen im
dezember 2020 rund 40 prozent höher als
im durchschnitt der vergangenen vier
jahre
bei den über 80 jährigen lag die zahl
der sterbefälle sogar 60 prozent höher
auf die bevölkerung gerechnet trifft es
thüringen mit 81,2 corona toten pro
100.000 einwohner am zweit schlimmsten
davor liegt nur sachsen und auch beim
impfen indra mühelos bundesland im rest
der republik hinterher
thüringen liegt nur auf platz zehn von
16 bundesländern dennoch lässiges darin
während der ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen für cdu-chef und
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet
undenkbar was herr ramelow da spielt
werden mp cars weiß ich nicht ich spiele
keine computerspiele während
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen weil es
in der tat um sehr sehr wichtige fragen
geht gamer ramelow dagegen erzählt bei
clubhouse munter erschaffe bis zu zehn
level während der stundenlangen
beratungen mit der kanzlerin inzwischen
hat er sich bei twitter zu seiner
clubhouse plauderei öffentlich geäußert
und sich entschuldigt allerdings nicht
fürs daddeln sondern nur für einen
anderen ausrutscher
ramelow nannte die kanzlerin in dem
gespräch merklichen ein krisen
bundesland regieren und in einer der
wichtigsten konferenz mit der kanzlerin
zocken geht das überhaupt zusammen
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit ich war
so abgelenkt dass ist bodo ramelow nicht
so ging aber jetzt mal wirklich
ernsthaft wie oft wenn es in einer
konferenz weil ein bisschen langweilig
wird oder mal so eine kleine atempause
drin ist für sie selbst im handy also
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich es ist es geht
hier um die mpk die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da geht es
um leben und tod es geht um
schwerwiegende entscheidung von denen
alle menschen betroffen sind ich glaube
dass keine pflegerin kein pfleger kein
einzelhändler niemand in thüringen
verständnis hat wenn der
ministerpräsident der eigentlich mit
diskutieren sollten nachdenken soll rum
da dort am handy das ist mir fehlen die
worte sie merken es völlig inakzeptabel
der wievielten sie eben gerade auch
schon gar nicht verstehen er war ganz
konkret welche konsequenzen muss man
daraus jetzt ableiten
na ja offensichtlich ist herr ramelow
nicht geeignet an solchen konferenzen
teilzunehmen
ich kenne ja auch die anderen
ministerpräsidenten die arbeiten hoch
konzentriert in diesen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen mit das
geht über viele stunden das ist
anstrengend keine frage der mann dadurch
darum ich habe dafür kein verständnis er
sollte sich jetzt entschuldigen bei die
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen den
ministerpräsidenten dass er dort nicht
aufgepasst hat aber vor allem sollte er
sich bei seiner bevölkerung
entschuldigen denn für sie sitzt er dort
er vertritt das land thüringen die
menschen aus thüringen und hat sich
nicht für deren interessen eingesetzt
hat nichts eingebracht hat dann handy
rum gezockt und dann macht er noch
schlechte macho witze insofern das ist
alles nicht zum lachen
du kannst ja so sein wir denken da wird
hoch konzentriert gearbeitet überstunden
und in wahrheit ist das völlig normal
das macht jeder unter dem tisch oder
geht man zwischendurch raus und so
weiter können sie hier sagen dass es
auch keinen
alle normal dass es absolut
außergewöhnlich das kommt bei den
anderen ministerpräsidenten nicht vor
also dass man rausgeht und einmal kurz
bei einer zehnstündigen sitzung sich ein
glas wasser holt oder ähnliches das ist
doch selbstverständlich
aber ich weiß von keinem anderen dass
der irgendwie auf die idee kommt dort
mit dem handy rum zu spielen also egal
ob armin laschet markus söder tobias hat
mich halt quatscht reiner haselhoff
volker bouffier die arbeiten der
wirklich gut vorbereitet über viele
stunden und insofern fehlt glaube ich
allen das verständnis dafür da am handy
herum zu spielen und übrigens das ist
das problem an dem was jetzt klar
geworden ist von herrn ramelow
das schafft doch dieses misstrauen
gegenüber regionale das trierer auch
alle und das ist übrigens der der der
der ganze sprich auch von von ganz links
und ganz rechts die afd benutzt das
nämlich dass bodo ramelow sich falsch
verhält und nicht aufpasst fällt auf
alle die hart arbeiten und konzentriert
sind zurück und das ist unmöglich
herzig sie forderten ja unter anderem
eine entschuldigung das ist nicht das
einzige was in diesem gespräch mit bodo
ramelow stattgefunden hat dass er gesagt
hat dass er candy kreis spielt er hat
auch noch was anderes gesagt er hat
nämlich die bundeskanzlerin als
merklichen bezeichnet dafür zumindest
hat er sich entschuldigt das wollen wir
uns hier einmal auf twitter ansehen er
schreibt eine kluge frau hat mir auf
clubhouse de gerade schlüssig den
eigentlichen fauxpas meiner clubhaus
plauderei dargelegt und es hat mich
überzeugt den namen der bundeskanzlerin
zu verniedlichen weihnacht männlicher
ignoranz dafür meine ehrliche bitte um
entschuldigung also dafür entschuldigt
er sich gleichzeitig sagte auch das ist
der eigentliche fauxpas klingt ja so als
sei das andere zuzugeben dass man auf
dem handy daddelt wären eine wichtige
konferenz läuft kein fauxpas
naja ich finde jetzt muss man sagen weil
einige ist die ganze zeit streiten macho
ramelow er hat sich für diesen macho
ramelow entschuldigt dass andere finde
ich genauso schwerwiegend dass man sich
nicht konzentriert auf wirklich wichtige
beschlüsse thüringen ist mit den zahlen
ganz oben und mit dem niveau
offensichtlich der mitarbeit ganz unten
und das ist auch ein großer skandal aber
wird so gelästert also das vielleicht
noch ein kleiner ins
von diesem tweet das eben ja vorher
diese plauderei der stadt fand auf der
plattform clubhouse dazu vielleicht
gleich noch ein bisschen mehr
da wurde eben ganz offen gesprochen
spricht man so hallt über kollegen
selbst über die bundeskanzlerin sagt man
da als ministerpräsidenten bei dass
merkel kennen das und das gemacht ja ich
tue es nicht und die anderen tun es auch
nicht und das hat nichts übrigens mit
clubhaus zu tun oder nicht klappt haus
sondern er hat tief in seinen denken
blicken lassen nämlich zwei dinge eben
wir über andere spricht über frauen
spricht wer über die bundeskanzlerin
ganz offensichtlich und dass er sich gar
nicht damit beschäftigt meine alle ehre
für für bild live ja dass er dann auch
noch sagt dass seine mitarbeiter bild
live verfolgen um mitzubekommen was dort
gerade diskutiert wird er spielt am
handy und macht dann noch witze über
andere
das kenne ich von keinem anderen
übrigens über parteigrenzen hinweg und
das ist für thüringen einfach schlimm
ist das etwas was einem rausrutschen
kann wenn man in einer app ist und sagt
das ist jetzt der neueste trend man weiß
es sind viele junge leute dort und man
möchte vielleicht seinem image ein
bisschen auf die sprünge helfen indem
man sagt ach jetzt erzähle ich mal so
einen kleinen schlenker aus den
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen ja er
hat sich er hat sich jetzt für die
äußerung entschuldigt aber dass er sich
nicht dass er nicht mitmacht dass er
sich nicht konzentriert dass er nicht
nachdenkt ist dass jetzt die richtige
entscheidung dass er nicht an die
menschen in thüringen denkt die darunter
zu leiden haben unter den
einschränkungen sondern dass er sich am
handy mit computerspielen beschäftigt
das ist doch der skandal nicht dass er
das bei clubhaus gesagt hat oder sonst
irgendwo dass er das tut das ist der
skandal
und dafür sollte er sich bei den
menschen in seinem bundesland
entschuldigen und bei seinen kolleginnen
und kollegen die davon ausgegangen sind
dass er aufpasst wenn er abstimmt dieses
clubhaus oder klappt hause wurde er als
alles sprechen sie sind auch dort was
planen sie da als cdu-generalsekretär
wie werden sie sich da verhalten werden
sie auch das ein oder andere anekdötchen
dann den nächsten stunden verbreiten ja
ich werde morgen abend auch bei
clubhouse talk machen zu verschiedenen
themen um 19 uhr
aber ich finde man sollte auch das ob
jetzt bei clubhouse oder sonst irgendwo
das auch sagen was man denkt wie man das
auch in der pressekonferenz sagt wie man
das in sitzungen macht man kann
vielleicht ein bisschen länger
diskutieren man kann ein bisschen auch
mal einen spaß machen darum geht es ja
gar nicht geht nicht um den spaß sondern
es geht darum dass man in einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht
mitgemacht hat sich nicht konzentriert
hat und da ging es um sehr viel
und es ging auch um leben und tod vielen
dank für das gespräch an den
cdu-generalsekretär poussin jack lang
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt auch mit
dem csu generalsekretär markus blume der
und zugeschaltet es aus münchen guten
abend herr blume
ich grüße sie hallo
es geht um ganz wichtige entscheidungen
für unser aller corona alltag es geht um
schulen und kitas um krankenhäuser im
altenheim um ganz viele jobs und
milliarden hilfen usw
und während diese entscheidung getroffen
werden spielt man auf dem handy candy
crash was sagt das aus
also ich bin ehrlich gesagt schon tief
betroffen dass sich bodo ramelow als
ministerpräsident eines landes hier als
spieler onkel gehört in der tat die der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz werden
weitreichende beschlüsse gefasst die
unser aller leben unmittelbar berühren
ich will nicht sagen dass da über leben
und tod entschieden wird aber natürlich
ist die frage der korona strategie eine
die entscheidend dafür ist denn wie
schnell es gelingt die infektionszahlen
und auch die todeszahlen nach unten zu
bringen
und dass jemand der in diesem gremium
dabei ist dann sagt er hat nichts
besseres zu tun als sich die zeit zu
vertreiben
10 level von kenny crash zu spielen ist
tatsächlich unverantwortlich wenn er uns
damit sagen will dass er amtsmüde ist
dann soll er einfach zurücktreten dann
hat er viel zeit zum spielen angst
verantwortlich welche konsequenzen
fordern sie denn jetzt konkret
handlungen
na ja also es wie gerade gesagt es gibt
einen weg dass man noch mehr zeit mit
handyspielen verbringen kann
es ist ein amt niederlegen und die er
machen was mich ärgert ist dass bodo
ramelow vor einigen wochen jahr frank
und frei zugestanden hat der kanzlerin
dass er gehört hat dass ihr
die falsche strategie eingeschlagen hat
ehrlich gesagt ist wundert dann
offensichtlich auch nicht wenn er in
solchen sitzungen nicht zuhört was von
expertenseite oder von der kanzlerin
vorgetragen wird und stattdessen am
handy spielt schlimm ist dass am ende
dann fehlentscheidung entstehen die dazu
führen dass thüringen in vielerlei
belangen einfach schlusslicht ist was
corona bekämpfung in deutschland angeht
auch beim bmz mit thüringen nach wie vor
nicht gut aus bei der zahl der zwei
impfungen liegt thüringen im absolut
letzten drittel ziemlich weit hinten am
ende also es wird alles ein sehr
schlechtes licht auf die art und weise
wie bodo ramelow sein amtsverständnis
als ministerpräsident wahrnimmt jetzt
könnte es ja sein dass das völlig normal
ist dass man sowas als politiker während
solcher videokonferenzen halt einfach
macht haben sie informationen wie die
anderen ministerpräsidenten damit
umgehend herr laschet hat sich heute
geäußert aber ist das ansonsten weit
verbreitet beispielsweise bei bayerns
ministerpräsident
oder können sie verdienen die hand ins
feuer legen dass er eben nicht nebenbei
welcher handy spiele treibt
ich kenne ehrlich gesagt nur
ministerpräsidenten die in diesen
sitzungen auch um die bedeutung dieser
gespräche bescheid wissen und sich ihrer
verantwortung bewusst sind
das sind intensivste beratungen da wird
gesungen um den richtigen weg und ich
kenne ehrlich gesagt niemanden der in
diesen fragen dann sagt mensch ich nehme
mir jetzt mal timeout und spiele ihre
zehn levels von irgend ein computerspiel
durch herzlichen dank für das gespräch
an den csu general markus blume danke
[Musik]
und das ringen um die impfstoff
lieferungen in die eu und nach
deutschland die haben weitere politische
konsequenzen offenbar gerade kommt ganz
frisch die nachricht aus brüssel dass
brüssel die eu nämlich sagt die
lieferschwierigkeiten lieferverzögerung
des impfstoffherstellers astrazeneca
seien nicht hinnehmbar und daraus folgt
dass die eu nun ganz offenbar über
ausfuhrkontrolle nachdenkt das müssen
wir ein bisschen erklären hier im studio
und das tun wir mit bild chefreporter
peter tiede peter das heißt
ausfuhrkontrolle
bisher wird es offenbar nicht
kontrolliert das heißt die usa andere
länder bekommen einfach den eben im
stoff den hier hergestellten und wir
bekommen weniger so eine situation gibt
es und dies bisher völlig legal
ja die ist also egal frei es ist der
freie warenverkehr wir haben gemeinsam
handelsraum auch mit den usa und wenn
ein hersteller wie zum beispiel
astrazeneca weltweit 20 werke hat dann
kann ja aus dem berg inhalt beliefern
wenig wie viel aber das ist bei so einer
entscheidenden sache wirklich kein
keinen überblick darüber gibt wie wird
eigentlich hergestellt hier und wie viel
geht geht wohin das überrascht schon zum
mal wieder zum teil auch die
produktionsstätten mit millionen oder
milliarden sogar aus dem eu topf und aus
dem nationalen aus den nationalen
haushalten fördern wir sehen gerade
nochmal den tweet von heute nachmittag
vom bundesgesundheitsminister und der
spricht dort er eben von ja eventuell
ausfuhrbeschränkungen iren sparen zu den
lieferengpässen des corona impfstoffs
die eu muss wissen können ob und welche
impfstoffe ausgeführt werden so können
wir nachvollziehen ob die eu-verträge
fair bedient werden eine pflicht zur
genehmigung von impfstoff exporten auf
eu-ebene ergibt sinn wir haben den den
suite nachmittag gesehen und haben erst
mal gedacht das gibts doch gar nicht
dass das nicht längst genau der fall ist
ja ich habe mich ein bisschen geärgert
weil ich war dem auf der spur und zwar
gibt es wirklich einen ungeheuren
verdacht
es gibt den verdacht dass andere länder
bedient werden dass die verträge erfüllt
werden namentlich die usa von
verschiedenen herstellern geht nicht nur
um astrazeneca es geht auch um an
der hersteller also auch in bayern keck
und wohl auch um moderner die alle in
europa werke haben und dass wir zum
beispiel die lieferungen reduziert
kriegen wenn irgendwo etwas aus wenn zum
beispiel wir haben in pures in belgien
die produktionsdrosselung bei jetzt in
diesem feuerwerk weil man da die
produktion ausbaut wikingern später mehr
aber wahrscheinlich das ist der verdacht
dem die man jetzt hat geht gleichzeitig
weiterhin von da etwas in die usa obwohl
es immer heißt die usa werden von daten
nicht beliefert bei astrazeneca ähnlich
da fällt irgendwo ein großes werk aus
und die eu soll dann wieder weniger
kriegen die hinweise die es gibt es das
in der eu reduziert wird aber die usa
kriegen gleichbleiben viel und das dass
es dann zu unseren lasten geht das aus
den werken die hier gefördert worden
sind die hier sind impfstoffe rausgehe
und das darf nicht sein das kann ich
sein und da empört man sich jetzt mal
wirklich zurecht und wir können nur
hoffen dass da dem riegel vorgeschoben
wird ein riegel vorgeschoben wird peter
wir wissen aber in der europäischen
union da mahlen die mühlen manchmal
etwas schwerfällig etwas langsam deshalb
mit der zustimmung der mitgliedstaaten
zu tun was glaubst du seine ausfuhrstopp
wie schnell wird das jetzt überhaupt
umsetzbar sein das kann ganz fix gehen
also es haben sich heute die 27
gesundheitsminister zusammengeschaltet
haben das problem besprochen haben sich
darauf geeinigt dass man jetzt erstmal
ab fragt was exportiert ihr was geht aus
den aus dem eu bereich aus ihren werken
hier raus wie hat wie viele habt ihr bei
anderen reduziert und wieviel reduziert
ihr bei uns astrazeneca für die eu
angekündigt jetzt 60 prozent weniger
lieferung im märz also ab denn die ab
dem februar ab dazu dass und die
zulassung soll nächsten freitag kommen
60 prozent reduzierung schlicht und
ergreifen wirklich nicht nicht
vernehmbar und dann hat man sich
entschieden wir fragen jetzt nach
weniger wieviel wohin wie viel war es
woanders reduziert worden
und wenn das nicht zu unserer
zufriedenheit ist dann machen wir auch
so beschränkungen das heißt er braucht
eine genehmigung und dann kann gesagt
wenn zuerst werden werden wir bedienen
und das was dann darüber hinaus geht
darf woanders hin also das ist eine
klare ansage gibt es nicht alle tage von
der eu dank an den bild chefreporter
peter tiede hier im studio also die
breaking news ist dass die eu über eine
ausfuhrkontrolle von niki in der eu
hergestellten impfstoff nachdenkt die
nachricht dahinter die uns alle empört
ist gibt es bisher leider nicht
[Musik]
die barrikaden randale in den
niederlanden kippt die stimmung grund
dafür ist die menschen sind mit den
strengeren corona regeln nicht
einverstanden ja es sind so sagte sogar
der bürgermeister von eindhoven
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände wenn man
diese bilder sieht bürgerkriegsähnliche
szenen holland im ausnahmezustand
eine brennende corona test stelle
tränengas wasserwerfer brennende autos
festnahmen
die korona bedingte ausgangssperre hat
in etwa zehn niederländischen städten am
wochenende zu protesten und krawallen
geführt
in der kleinstadt nördlich von amsterdam
protestieren dutzende menschen schon am
späten samstagabend gegen die
sperrstunde
wie die polizei am sonntag mitteilte
warfen die demonstranten steine und
feuerwerkskörper auf polizisten und
demolierten polizeiautos jugendliche
stecken nach polizeiangaben auch ein
corona testzentrum des gesundheitsamtes
in brand in amsterdam gerät am sonntag
eine protestversammlung von rund 1500
menschen völlig außer kontrolle mit
hunden und wasserwerfern versucht die
polizei die versammlung aufzulösen
mindestens 100 menschen werden in der
stadt festgenommen
nach angaben lokaler medien regeln
polizeikräfte die residenz der
bürgermeisterin haben
ich bin mit der aktuellen politik in
holland nicht einverstanden und finde
dass unsere freiheit eingeschränkt wird
ja es gibt viele gefährdete alte
menschen aber es gibt auch viele junge
und die jungen sind die zukunft unseres
landes
ähnliche bilder auch in eindhoven auch
hier kommt es zu massiven
ausschreitungen bei einer demonstration
gegen die korona maßnahmen die
bereitschaftspolizei braucht stunden um
den platz vor dem hauptbahnhof zu räumen
genau wie in amsterdam werden sogar
wasserwerfer eingesetzt
trotzdem werden teile des bahnhofs
massiv zerstört es kommt sogar zu
plünderungen
55 personen werden hier festgenommen in
einer stellungnahme gegenüber der presse
befürchtet eindhovens bürgermeister
einen bürgerkrieg wenn es so weitergeht
auch in den haag tilburg enschede venlo
ram und breda arnheim und appeldorn
kommt es am sonntag zu unruhen
krankenhäuser werden mit steinen
angegriffen die illegale partys mit 100
menschen müssen aufgelöst werden seit
samstagnacht herrscht in den
niederlanden erstmals seit beginn der
korona pandemie eine ausgangssperre
die bürger müssen von 21 uhr bis 4 uhr
30 in ihren wohnungen bleiben schon in
der ersten nacht verhängte die polizei
wegen verstößen gegen die sperre
landesweit mehr als 3600 geldstrafen
mehr als 200 randalierer werden am
wochenende wegen der ausschreitungen
verhaftet erst am sonntag gegen
mitternacht kehrt wieder ruhe ein
wie sieht es heute an diesem montagabend
in den niederlanden aus michael
engelberg unser kollege ist in venlo
ja michael wie sieht es dort jetzt heute
hand aus wird und werden dort weitere
ausschreitungen befürchtet und davon
gibt es ja ja also du hast völlig recht
ich stehe mit dem kamera
das ist sowieso eine dreiviertelstunde
aus dem ruhrgebiet entfernt
und ganz ehrlich wir steht jetzt ja
schon knapp eine stunde null ist kommen
tatsächlich immer wieder jugendliche
vorbei die auch sehr sehr grimmig gucken
das ist so eine szene event touristen
vielleicht auch krawallbrüder und hier
muss man sagen dass in den niederlanden
tatsächlich richtig der kessel dampft
ich gehe mal ein stück zur seite man
kann das hier nochmal sehen an einem
geschäft gegenüber des bahnhofs die
scheibe wirklich komplett kaputt
man hat sie jetzt einfach so gelassen
das ist doppelt verglast noch nicht wir
gehen jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter dann
sehen wir gleich hier auf der rechten
seite haben die geschäftsinhaber das
wirkliche demolierte schaufenster mit
holz zusammen gezimmert das ist hier
direkt am jetzt ist ja ein bisschen die
kamera jetzt können wir wieder die
kamera umgedreht dass sie haben die
fenster hier mit holz l zusammengehalten
das ist hier direkt am bahnhof muss
sagen dass in den niederländer in den
niederlanden tatsächlich seit wochen und
monaten ist richtig brodelt anfangs hat
man hier tatsächlich die ganze sache
schleifen lassen
er hat man nicht richtig durchgegriffen
und der abend lockt er ist jetzt zeigt
seit freitag samstag hat ja zugegriffen
um 21 uhr muss ja alles nicht sein und
da muss man sagen dass die leute da
tatsächlich richtig gegen oft beginnen
am wochenende die nicht angemeldeten
demonstration zum beispiel in amsterdam
und eindhoven die haben die polizei noch
mal richtig voll in der tatsachen
gestellt und ich habe heute lange mit
einem kollegen vom telegrafen gesprochen
das ist die größte zeitung hier in den
niederlanden und er hat gesagt
tatsächlich habe man angst vor einem
bürgerkrieg und man gehe davon aus dass
es zentrale aktionen der leute gibt um
den start hier wirklich richtig mürbe zu
machen und es kommt natürlich für die
nieder denn da gerade alles zusammen von
einer woche ist die regierung das
kabinett von margaret thatcher getreten
ist sind nur noch tatsächlich einzelner
minister im amt unter anderem auch der
innenminister und michael ganz kurz ganz
kurz weil du diese starke wort
bürgerkrieg auch gerade in den mund
genommen hast einige experten sprechen
ja ebenfalls von bürgerkrieg der
bürgermeister von eindhoven hat gesagt
das was auf der straße passiert das ist
so was wie der mittelfinger für all die
die sich gerade solidarisch an die
korona regeln halten das sind ja krasse
worte die da benutzt werden also wie
dicht steht man tatsächlich vor so einer
art bürgerkrieg dort in den niederlanden
also die sozialen medien rufen in den
sozialen medien rufen natürlich viele
leute auf zur plünderung das ist ja das
was ihr gerade auch nochmal geschildert
habe den eindruck
bis heute mittag wirklich dabei was die
polizei aufgezogen um plünderungen zu
verhindern
ich gehe davon aus dass das jetzt gegen
abend noch einmal
nochmal verstärkt wird es kam immer
wieder immer wieder auch jugendliche
schwarz gekleidet hier vorbei und ich
denke
die niederlande haben tatsächlich angst
dass sie irgendwie was passieren kann
und ja man kann eigentlich nur hoffen
dass die polizei dass hier im griff hat
und anders als in deutschland ist es zb
in den niederlanden so dass die
bürgermeister auch der erste polizist
sind ähnlich wie das in den landkreisen
ist wenn der landrat der polizeibehörde
vorsteht
hier ist das auch so und die vereinigung
der bürgermeister haben heute nochmal
dazu aufgerufen sämtliche
demonstrationen was die korona regeln
betrifft wirklich im keim zu ersticken
dass sie gar nicht erst stattfinden
können und hat auch noch mal die bürger
der einzelnen städte aufgerufen sich
solidarisch zu erklären zusammenzuhalten
nämlich nur so könne man zusammen dass
corona virus eindämmen
und tatsächlich im abendkleid von 21 uhr
bis 34 wirklich zu hause zu bleiben
damit möglichst schnell alle wieder auf
die straße können weil das muss man hier
wirklich sagen das hat den niederlanden
sind sehr erschüttert komplett alle
zeitungen waren heute davon durchfall
auch da wurde von bürgerkrieg gesprochen
und man muss wirklich sagen dass die
polizei und die ordnungsbehörden hier
von dieser kommenden nacht tatsächlich
angst haben michael engelberg in venlo
vielen dank für deine einschätzungen die
stimmung in den niederlanden kippt und
das ist grund genug für uns hier einmal
auf die stimmung in deutschland in
lockdown deutschland zu schauen und
vergleichen der die werte mit dem
dezember 2020 so kann man eine kleine
umkehr ist stellen also im dezember 2020
waren 57 prozent zufrieden mit den
maßnahmen der regierung 54 prozent
weniger zufrieden und jetzt immer januar
sieht es umgekehrt fast aus 46 prozent
sind zufrieden und 54 prozent sind
weniger zufrieden mit den maßnahmen der
bundesregierung der gründe für die
unzufriedenheit gibt es natürlich in
deutschland genug die schulen sind
weiterhin zu die altenheime werden immer
noch nicht ausreichend geschützt und
darüber stritten und diskutierten auch
heftig christian lindner und karl
lauterbach der gesundheitsexperte von
der spd und der chef der fdp gestern bei
unserem talk die richtigen fragen wir
müssen jetzt bund länder die
landkreise die niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte und die
pharmazeutische industrie an einen tisch
bringen und überlegen wie kann die
logistik alleine schon besser werden
beim impfen wenn ich höre dass
hochbetagte menschen hohe 80 mit dem
taxi und den dem rollator zum ins
zentrum fahren dort dann möglicherweise
stehend warten müssen dann noch eine
längere beratung bekommen bevor sie
geimpft sind dann muss das besser und
leichter organisierten frustrierend dass
nicht wieder hin stoffel da ist übrigens
dieser liegt bist du dich es jetzt gibt
von bayern tag war das bergen first also
vergrößert wird die auch so werden nur
relativ große zahl dann aber wir werden
einen engagierten und gut funktionieren
dann doch dort parken weil insbesondere
die neuen varianten die jetzt kommen
diese von an ganz anderen kaliber das
ist noch einmal eine ganz andere
hausnummer
wir haben noch mal ein ganz anderes
bedrohungspotenzial und wir müssen uns
fragen führen das können wir nicht weg
kämpfen somit also bringt da nichts
anderes als das was wir jetzt machen wir
müssen dann versuchen mit einem
effizienten guten lockdown die zahlen
und was so ein wunder zu bekommen dass
wir die familien können bekommen so dass
wir mehr
ein polizeieinsatz in einem wohnhaus in
münchen ein mann wird von zwei
polizisten erst jahr kräftig angepackt
dann anschließend am boden festgehalten
der wehrt sich das geht dann einige
sekunden so aber die polizisten die
greifen hart durch sie können den mann
schließlich unter kontrolle bringen doch
das was sie hier sehen das war nicht
etwa ein einsatz in der drogenszene hier
gab es keine prügelei vorher oder so was
die polizisten wollten eine wohnung rein
um zu schauen ob da gegen korona regeln
verstoßen wird
und genau das ist der grund weshalb
dieser einsatz jetzt zum streitthema
wird war dieses heftige hinlangen der
polizisten wirklich verhältnismäßig
erschreckende bilder von einem
polizeieinsatz in münchen ende märz
letzten jahres mit folgen für beide
seiten
aussage steht gegen aussage was war
passiert
dimitrios asteras wohnt zusammen mit
seiner freundin und seiner vierjährigen
tochter in münchen bogenhausen an jenem
abend schaut auch eine verwandte seiner
lebensgefährtin auf einen kaffee vorbei
sagt asteras dann habe seine ex frau
angerufen und dabei die stimmen der
anwesenden im hintergrund gehört sie
aber einen corona party vermutet und die
polizei alarmiert und um 18 uhr klingt
das hinten und ich kann schon mal in die
tür gemacht ich die tür auf und sehe ich
vor mir zwei polizisten die war auch
eine maske und handschuhe
unser ja hallo sage ich ja wir haben
einen anruf bekommen dass sie hier party
machen wir haben schon von anfang an die
tür zum eingreifen dass sie ihre
einkommen dann drücke ich die tür ist
die tür so richtig ein kleines geht es
ganz normal nach paar sekunden
die tür aufmachen ganz normal da ich
bitteschön ein bild was brauchen sie und
alles mein ausweis runden im auto bin
nicht aus und ich habe meinen schlüssel
die damit schon da und sie macht das
video und der polizisten der wärme des
hier und da anders geht da was bei uns
ich mein ausweis gar nicht anzeigen
dann fängt dann wenn wir nicht rein
kommen dann gehen wir nicht wer ich sage
ganz normal ja und sagt ja jetzt starb
starb
ich bitte ich versuche die tür
zuzumachen dass wir in die wir gehen und
dann sind sie mir dann kommt der andere
beamte und fängt mir auch gleich zum
eingreifen
die polizei überwindet inhalt sei ein
schwerverbrecher obwohl hier nur
verdächtigt wird besuch empfangen zu
haben
überraschend die beamten dulden dass
seine freundin alles filmt sogar das
gespräch mit dem herbeigeeilten
vorgesetzten danach die folge für
dimitrios asteras eine anklage wegen
widerstands gegen angriff auf
vollzugsbeamte in tateinheit mit
vorsätzlicher körperverletzung einer der
polizisten fordert von ihm rund 4600
euro schmerzensgeld wegen einer
gebrochenen hand bilddaten münchner
polizei um eine stellungnahme
doch die hält sich bedeckt
ein sprecher bestätigte lediglich am
telefon dass es am 27 märz 2020 in der
großen straße einen einsatz wegen eines
möglichen verstoßes gegen das
infektionsschutz gegeben habe und dass
die betroffene person wegen widerstands
gegen vollstreckungsbeamte angezeigt
worden sein
über vorwürfe gegen die eingesetzten
polizisten wusste er nichts wenn es hier
eine anzeige geben sollte wegen
möglicher körperverletzung im amt müsste
das bayerische landeskriminalamt
ermitteln
ein polizeieinsatz in corona zeiten der
zum streitthema wird darüber wollen wir
jetzt noch einmal sprechen diesen
einsatz analysieren mit unserem polizei
experten hier aus berlin
ich grüße dich bis ans zugeschaltet
gerade matthias becker matthias wir
haben die bilder gesehen von diesem
harten zupacken der beiden polizisten in
corinna zeiten offenbar ging es da um
kontrolle für zu nichteinhaltung der
krone regel in dieser wohnung was siehst
du in diesem einsatz hartes
unberechtigtes hin lang der polizisten
also der einsatz als ich das video heute
bei bild gesehen habe hat mich
schockiert er hat so viele fehler beim
einschreiten schon am anfang von den
beiden polizeibeamten zutage gebracht
dass ich gar nicht weiß wo ich anfangen
soll halten wir doch mal die fakten fest
eine frau ruft an und sagt ich habe das
gefühl da ist eine paten also alle
polizisten die hieraus corona streife
auch in berlin immer nur einen anruf
haben die müssen doch selbst zur anfahrt
und vor dem objekt selbst von der
wohnung erst mit ihrer eigenen
wahrnehmung einschalten und zu gucken
ist das stimmengewirr ist der laute
musik sind die betroffenen personen
vielleicht alkoholisiert angriffslustig
oder renitent all das ist ja hier nicht
passiert der mann war ja wirklich am
anfang der woche hat seiner
lebensgefährtin noch beschwichtigt und
beruhigt und jetzt müssen wir doch als
polizisten auch eines sehen wenn ein
polizist an einer tür klingelt und eine
frau sie ist ein vierjähriges kind
darf ich oder sollte ich wenn ich keinen
widerstand provozieren will auf jeden
fall erstmal bitten den mann vor die tür
zu kommen die tür vielleicht hinter sich
zu schließen und dann fühle ich mit ihm
ein gespräch das darf niemals zur
maßregelung vor den augen oder ohren des
kindes geschehen
und jetzt macht der polizist noch eins
er will in diese wohnung rein welche
tatsache rechtfertigen denn die annahme
dass dort eine party ist das video was
ich gesehen habe zeigt eigentlich nur
eins da ist ein nettes kleines kirchen
die haben ein kleines vierjähriges
mädchen in der wohnung und ja und und
leben ihre gesunde zeit und diamant ist
sogar noch staatstragend er ist immer
noch sehr höflich und freundlich und was
macht der polizist er will auf biegen
und brechen in diesem wohnung nein also
selbst wenn mir ex-polizist jemand
erklärt da kommt nicht in die wohnung
ein
dann sage ich okay ich warte jetzt vor
der tür und hole mir eine richterliche
genehmigung für diese durch suche stehe
matthias sohn wir haben diesen
würgegriff auch eben gesehen ist es
völlig normal in solchen situationen
naja gut als alsdann ich sag mal der
unmittelbaren zwang einsetzte spricht
dass bürger und auch den mann
ich sag mal überwältigend dann ist das
aber das ist ja schon alles eskaliert da
sind ja vorher schon so viele fehler
durch die eingesetzten beamten gemacht
bauen die verhältnismäßigkeit der mittel
wenn ich mir diese bilder anschaue da
gibt es einen anrufer behaupten und da
könnte eventuell eine party statt sind
und mal ganz ehrlich die gesundheit der
allgemeinheit und das quartier so aus wo
ist denn da bitteschön nur
gefahrenabwehr nun matthias können wir
nicht hundertprozentig sagen was vorher
vorgefallen ist vielleicht können wir
eine kurze sequenz dieses video sonst
noch einmal kurz gemeinsam anschauen da
ist der ton vor allem wichtig
dann dort rufen sie haben die lösung
kommen
und zwar jetzt rufen sie
matthias dieses hey hey hey der beamten
vorher lässt darauf schließen dass
vielleicht doch vorher irgendetwas
passierte ist auszuschließen dass
derjenige vorher irgendwie in richtung
der waffe gegriffen hat oder irgendwie
sich die beamten bedroht fühlten in
dieser situation siehst du da so etwas
entlasten das was wir in dem video nicht
sehen was möglicherweise auch
abgeschnitten sein könnte vorher also
dieses hey hey hey könnte ich nur so
deuten
der polizeibeamte hat grundsätzlichen
auf der straße tätig ist keine freunde
hat nur seinen kollegen wie hey hey hey
geschichte könnte sein dass wir bei
andere sich bedroht fühlte weil jetzt
der der betroffene der wohnungsinhaber
vielleicht den beamten erklären wollte
und die hand vielleicht in richtung des
beamten behoben hat um zu sagen ich
mache das hier schon was auch immer da
geschehen ist aber ich sehe nicht ein
griff an die waffel sehe da gar nichts
in der richtung wir können nur das
beurteilen was wir in dem video sehen
danke polizeiexperte matze becker für
das gespräch und wir wollen noch eine
weitere frage darzustellen denn und es
hat dieses video beschäftigt weil es da
ja um kontrolle in corona zeiten geht
und das wollen wir klären mit dem
strafverteidiger rabanne funk der uns
zugeschaltet ist wir haben in dem video
ja auch gesehen erfolg schönen guten
abend dass der polizeibeamte relativ
schnell gesagt hat sonst komme ich rein
in die wohnung wann darf der das
eigentlich der polizeibeamte darf in die
wohnung nur ein wenn er ihn wieder
eine straftat ermittelt
oder wenn er eine gefahr abwenden will
dann aber auch nur dann kommt es wieder
drauf an
entweder mit richterlicher genehmigung
also an der richterlichen beschluss das
ist der grundsatz
und nur bei gefahr im verzug und darüber
hinaus daneben gefahrenabwehr recht auch
nur in besonderen fällen kann er
eigenständig beziehungsweise auf
anordnung des staatsanwalts hat im
polizeirecht gefahrenabwehr recht spielt
die staatsanwaltschaft keine wirkliche
rolle
das heißt herr funk wenn ich hier
nachhaken darf das bedeutet für menschen
die von der polizei kontrolliert werden
in zeiten von corona wo treffen mit
mehreren personen zu hause verboten sind
man muss die beamten überhaupt gar nicht
hereinlassen und welche pflicht hat man
überhaupt zu erfüllen welche auskunft
muss man geben
ich würde grundsätzlich erst mal
folgendes klar stehen
die polizei darf all das was das gesetz
der polizei erlaubt
der bürger darf all das was ihm nicht
verboten ist
wenn es jetzt um das betreten einer
wohnung geht dann kommt es eben darauf
an was erwartet die polizei
eine information gibt es sind mehrere
personen zusammen und ist ein
infektionsrisiko
er kann die natürlich schon
gefahr im verzug annehmen und könnte
auch die wohnung betrieben aber nicht
durchsuchen
das ist hier der wichtige unterschied
und ich rate immer folgendes
das a und o ist die kommunikation auf
beiden seiten ruhig bleiben
fragen was möchte man durchsetzen worum
geht's welche maßnahmen steht an worauf
stützt sich diese maßnahmen
und warum bedarf es dieser maßnahme wenn
man diese drei punkte ab fragt dazu noch
ein bisschen abstand hält zu den
polizeibeamten also nicht in
unmittelbarer nähe ist vielleicht zu 23
meter weg dann sollte es eigentlich gut
verlaufen und vernünftig es gibt
natürlich so weit sein
danke ravern funk der strafverteidiger
zu ihrer stellungnahme zu diesem jahr
umstrittenen und aufrüttelnden
polizeieinsatz video das uns zugespielt
wurde und das aber auch zeigt wie wir
alle in diesen corona zeiten mit sich
dauernd ändernden regeln ja teilweise
überfordert sind und eben die beamten
ganz offensichtlich auch erst recht wenn
diese regeln die gemacht werden so
schwer durchsetzbar und kontrollierbar
sind dank erfolg unserer mutigen
soldaten mussten im fernen afghanistan
um ihr leben kämpfen überwachen im
afrikanischen mali den friedensprozess
aber wenn es darum geht in dieser corona
krise die altenheime zu schützen
ja dann sagt die politik zwei soldaten
oder soldatinnen die tests durchführen
nein das geht nicht
vor zwei wochen sagte bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel 14.000 einmal zwei
personen das sind 28.000 soldaten das
kann die bundeswehr auch nicht wuppen
doch viele experten nicht sagen
natürlich kann die bundeswehr das wuppen
wenn die politik es denn will
aber jetzt wollen wir uns einmal genauer
ansehen wo ist die bundeswehr derzeit in
dieser corona krise überhaupt eingesetzt
hier und da sehen wir schnelltests in
altenheime genau 1,1 prozent der
mehrheit arbeitet in den
gesundheitsämtern leitet leistet weitere
amtshilfe eine impfkampagne natürlich
auch in den alten und pflegeheim an
anderer stelle sind soldaten und
soldatinnen eingesetzt
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat sich heute in berlin ein
bild davon gemacht wie die bundeswehr in
einem pflegeheim arbeitet er sie kamen
dort am im vivantes pfleger in john f
kennedy das hat sie besucht und sich
dort auch wir sehen direkt testen lassen
eben mit hilfe der bundeswehr und auf
twitter schreibt ackermann
mit 10.000 soldaten und soldatinnen
bereit sobald anträge ausländern und
landkreisen kommen ja und genau hier ist
der haken es muss eben erst anträge
kommen es muss erst anträge kommen damit
dann die hilfe kommt und diese hilfe
kommt eben dann manchmal zu spät
der politische druck steigt in dieser
sache und deswegen hat sich auch
regierungssprecher steffen seibert heute
dazu geäußert sie wissen das ist der
bundesregierung ein großes anliegen
mitzuhelfen und pflegeheime und
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe zu
unterstützen dabei dass dort antigen
schnelltests zum einsatz kommen können
denn erstens lässt sich so verhindern
dass das virus in dieser einrichtungen
eindringt und zweitens hilft dass die
besucher zu ermöglichen die menschlich
so wichtig sind klar ist dass die
einrichtungen dafür personal brauchen in
einem ersten schritt kann die bundeswehr
mit ihren soldaten und soldatinnen da
eine große hilfe sein und ist es zum
teil auch schon landkreise und
kreisfreie städte müssen nur ihren
bedarf ermitteln und melden um diesen
prozess noch zu beschleunigen hatte der
chef des bundeskanzleramtes minister
brown in der vergangenen woche an die
landräte und die oberbürgermeister
geschrieben und es ist gut zu sehen dass
dieses angebot immer weiter angenommen
wird am vergangenen donnerstag
beispielsweise waren noch etwa 600
soldaten konkret im einsatz in einem
heim zugeordnet heute sind es schon etwa
1400 also dieser einsatz läuft hoch aber
natürlich das haben wir auch immer
gesagt hat die bundeswehr noch deutlich
mehr kapazitäten für diese unterstützung
in der ersten phase ist also zu hoffen
dass es nun auch immer mehr
anforderungen aus den kreisen und
städten geben wird der general ag erich
fahrt war sieben jahre lang der
wichtigste militärische berater der
bundeskanzlerin und ist uns jetzt auch
zugeschaltet guten abend herr vaart
vielen dank für ihre zeit ja wie
bewerten sie derzeit die arbeit der
bundesregierung in dieser krise gut oder
schlecht oder in der mitte naja das ist
ein schwieriges thema man muss einfach
sehen aus das bundeskanzleramt hier
massiv gefordert ist die regierung
selber die bundeskanzlerin selber
aber sie ist natürlich konfrontiert mit
14 verschiedenen ministerien die alle
ihre rechte beanspruchen die
verfassungsrechtliche und stark ins
gewicht haben sie hat 16
ministerpräsidenten zu koordinieren und
dann 27 mitgliedstaaten der eu
abzustimmen das ist alles sehr schwierig
aber wir brauchen national doch eine
stärkere steuerung und koordinierung aus
dem kanzleramt heraus es kann eigentlich
so nicht weitergehen und wir brauchen
eine politische strategie die auch
fokussiert ist auf den bereich der
wirklich am ärgsten betroffen sind und
das sind die alten und
pflegeeinrichtungen und die
hauptrisikogruppe das muss man endlich
in den fokus nehmen ich denke man das
hatte man auch erkannt aber es war
eigentlich schon vor einem jahr absehbar
dass man das dass die großbaustelle ist
und dass man darauf letztlich alles
ausrichtet einschließlich der bundeswehr
und das bedeutet natürlich dass die
militärs die bundeswehr klare politische
priorisierungen brauchen sie brauchen
und letztlich eine politische
entscheidung was gewollt ist und in
welchen bereichen sie eingesetzt werden
was man mit der bundeswehr macht derzeit
flächendeckend und überall auszuhelfen
das ist symptomatisch für den
gesamtzustand des krisenmanagements in
der korona pandemie wie man versucht
alles zu schützen
jedem nachzugehen und am ende schützt
man doch sehr wenig und kommt nicht
voran in der krisenbewältigung deswegen
ist fokussierung auf die alten und
pflegeeinrichtung sehr wichtig und da
kann die bundeswehr wie die
verteidigungsministerien ja auch gesagt
hat schon an entscheidenden beitrag
leisten
dennoch heißt es ja zwei soldaten oder
soldatinnen vor jedem pflegeheimen das
kann die bundeswehr nicht wir wollen uns
die augen führen 184 soldaten und
soldatinnen haben wir in der bundeswehr
dazu 10.000 reservisten es ist sehr
schwer sehr schwer vorstellbar dass wir
es nicht schaffen
zwei soldaten und soldatinnen für die
tests vor altenheimen und pflegeheim
einzusetzen
ja sie haben recht das kann die
bundeswehr sicherlich und das wird sie
auch machen aber dann müssen auch klare
politische vorgaben kommen es muss auch
eine priorisierung erfolgen die
bundeswehr hat der laufende einsätze
auch im ausland und sie hatte ihren
laufenden betrieb also da muss gesagt
werden von der politik auch sehr
deutlich das ist jetzt unser schwerpunkt
die alten und pflegeeinrichtungen und
hier sollen soll die bundeswehr ein
massiv wein auch mit personal und dann
wird sie das auch gruppen und stemmen
da bin ich sicher also sie kann es
stimmen derzeit aber ist es der ebenso
dass die länder und die landkreise
anträge stellen müssen offenbar erfolg
das nicht genug und auch nicht schnell
genug was kann er die bundesregierung
tun müsste man diesen prozess nicht
umdrehen müsste da einfach nicht noch
mehr initiative kommen ja ich finde auch
das muss proaktiv plötzlich von der
regierung kommen von den politischen
entscheidungsträgern und dann kann das
letztlich die armee auch umsetzen und
diesen dieses sich verlassen auf
bürokratische gänge von unten nach oben
und bis die anträge vorliegen und so
weiter ich verhalte das nicht mehr
verlage gerecht deutschland ist quasi in
einem katastrophalen zustand was die
pandemie anbelangt und wir sind hier
massiv gefordert und müssen da endlich
auch proaktiv rein und das im top
downloads von oben nach unten und es
kann nicht sein dass jeder
ministerpräsident sein eigenes ding
dreht hier in dieser krise nicht das
muss wirklich gesteuert werden aus dem
kanzleramt ich sage es nochmal trotz der
rechtlichen grauzone ich meine so ein
bisschen so an esprit was helmut schmidt
1962 bei der flutkatastrophe in hamburg
hat er das wäre jetzt angezeigt mich und
ich kann es auch nicht mehr hören als
bürger diese talkrunden mit denen jenen
die verschärfungen wollen und die
anderen die es lockerer sehen und so
weiter mir fehlte wirklich die
stringente politische führung aus einem
guss und das krisen-management ressort
übergreifend fokussiert auf die haupt
risikogruppen auf die ich wiederhole
noch mal alten und pflegeeinrichtungen
das fehlt mir aber trotzdem
herr vater noch mal nachgefragt weil das
genau wütend macht und weil das auch so
unverständlich ist wenn sie sagen wir
könnten aber wir werden einfach nicht
gefragt ist das eine schlampigkeit wenn
es nach so langer zeit immer noch um
zuständigkeiten geht die irgendwie im
wege steht man muss das doch kapiert
haben genau wie sich sagen dass das eine
solche
ja gewaltige krise ist in der es eben
nicht als zuständigkeit ich
zuständigkeit streitigkeiten scheitern
darf das heißt woran mangelt es dass der
schlampigkeit wollen die nicht haben
dies nicht verstanden
naja man will sich natürlich auch
regierungsseitig rechtlich absichern ich
meine man will sich abstimmen mit den
anderen europäischen partnern
man will sich abstimmen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten wohl jeder so eigene
vorschläge hat und ideen hat und so
sieht das ja auch aus letztlich beim
krisen management bezogen auf die
pandemie aber das geht so nach meiner
meinung nicht mehr weiter hier muss klar
und politisch gesteuert werden aus dem
kanzleramt heraus mit klaren vorgaben
auch an die bundeswehr auch an das
verteidigungsministerium aber nicht nur
da vielen herzlichen dank herr vaart für
ihre einschätzungen und vier für ihre
analyse dieses so schwierigen themas in
einen schönen abend danke berlin
ja und jetzt wollen wir uns einmal die
aktuellen zahlen ansehen die das ak
jeden morgen herausgibt und diese zahlen
hat unsere kollegin sina stinshoff im
gezogen
[Musik]
dankeschön patricia und kein wir wollen
wir immer auf die aktuellen zahlen des
robert-koch-instituts schauen und das
machen wir auf unserem radar
wir beginnen mit den neuinfektionen
damit das lka heute 6729 neuinfektionen
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden im
vergleich zur vorwoche sind das weniger
7141 neuinfektionen gab es noch am
montag vor einer woche allerdings muss
man dazu sagen da fehlten auch noch
einige zahlen aus dem bundesland
rheinland pfalz schauen wir uns die
situation an bei den todesfällen im
zusammenhang mit krone auch diese zahl
ist heute relativ niedrig 217 menschen
sind mit oder an in corona virus
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden
verstorben der höchstwert dem gab es am
14 januar mit über 1.200 krone toten ja
und dass die zahlen zurückgehen das
zeigt auch diese grafik das sind nämlich
die fälle von den montag im januar oder
sehen wir dass am ersten montag im
januar also am vierten erster gab es
noch fast 10.000 fälle am elften ersten
leichten anstiegs ist dieser bogen nach
oben sagt kleine peak da gab es 12.500
neuansteckungen und am 18
7141 das haben wir gerade auch schon
gesagt und heute eben 6729
neuinfektionen das ist dieser knick nach
unten also die zahlen gehen in die
richtige richtung nämlich runter das
sehen wir auch auf der karte denn es
gibt keinen pinken hotspot mehr also
keinen super hot spot mit einer
incidents von über 500 also keinen
pinken landkreis mehr und wir sehen auch
das ist hier immer heller wird also
hellrot es kommen immer mehr gelbe
flecken hinzu das heißt das hier ist
infektionsgeschehen zurückgeht aber es
gibt noch einen super hot spot mit
incidence über 400 und 2
der burgenlandkreis in sachsen anhalt
hat eine instanz von 452 und das hat
jetzt auch konsequenzen für die bewohner
dort denn ab morgen gilt und eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre das heißt die
menschen müssen ja zu hause bleiben nach
21 uhr darf das haus nicht mehr ohne
einen triftigen grund verlassen werden
schauen jetzt auch die situation in den
krankenhäusern an da sehen wir das ab
22.000 56 intensivbetten in ganz
deutschland belegt sind davon 4616 durch
corona patienten und frei sind aktuell
noch 4793 betten in ganz deutschland und
zum schluss wollen wir noch auf die
geimpften schauen auch diese zahl gibt
das ja jetzt jeden tag bekannt wie viele
menschen in deutschland mittlerweile
gegen das corona virus geimpft sind und
das sind mittlerweile über 1,7 millionen
menschen allerdings die meisten von
ihnen müssen noch die zweite impfung
erhalten die sind ja dann erst in
vollkommenen schutz haben sie dann und
wie ihr seht auf der karte alles was
dunkel grün eingefärbt ist dass es das
land bundesland ist quasi schon
fortschrittlich ist beim impfen die
impfen pro einwohner hat besonders viel
dass es unter anderem mecklenburg
vorpommern aber auch rheinland pfalz und
auch bayern ist weit vorne bei den
impfungen mit dabei soweit also die
aktuellen zahlen trotz sinkender
neuinfektionen wird er lockt dann aber
noch bis mindestens mitte februar
anhalten
grund dafür ist die angst der ausweitung
von corona mutation weil die sind ja
mittlerweile auch schon bei uns in
deutschland angekommen
in berlin ist eine ganze klinik
geschlossen 2000 menschen stehen unter
quarantäne und die klinik hat heute dazu
eine video pressekonferenz gegeben
positive proben mit der b11 variante
identifiziert worden sind die von uns
bekannten patienten standen das heißt
dass da von patienten die schon als
crooner positiv identifizieren sind die
dann aber nach typisiert worden sind im
verlauf der woche kamen drei weitere
hinzu auch mitarbeiter und wir haben bis
freitag das auf der immer wieder
einzelne fälle gehabt aber keine große
anzahl von fällen zu gekommen ist so
dass wir aktuell bei zwölf patienten im
vivantes humboldt klinikum und zehn
mitarbeitern sind also 22 nachweisen
dieser england variante und insgesamt
bei knapp 63 patienten die generell
positiv sind
wir sind in ständigen austausch mit
herrn laut aber auch mit dem gesamten
gesundheitsamt in reinickendorf und
hatten auch am wochenende kontakt zu
robert koch institut sind dass auch alle
weiteren vorgänge abgestimmt sind und
wir uns der expertise oder auch diese
experten meinen natürlich dann auch
unter anschließen und das auch so
umsetzen wie das volk so weit also die
aktuelle situation in der humboldt
klinik hier in berlin und wir haben eben
auch über die aktuellen geimpften zahlen
gesprochen und das geht bei uns ja nur
schleppend voran
weil eben zu wenig impfstoff da ist
jetzt hat aber die bundesregierung ein
anti corona medikament gekauft und das
im großen stil das soll jetzt helfen bei
der behandlung und wie das ganze
funktioniert darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit professor doktor theodor
dingermann erstmal jetzt live
zugeschaltet guten abend herr dingermann
ja gut das medikament wovon wir jetzt
sprechen das hat ja auch schon
ex-us-präsident donald schwamm bekommen
vielleicht können sie uns mal erklären
wie funktioniert das ganze überhaupt
hier geht es um zwei antikörper zwei
monoklonale antikörper die gemeinsam
informiert werden und diese monoklonale
antikörper binden an das protein des
saas kopf 2 virus und verhindern dadurch
dass dieses saß kauf 2 virus an den
anderes eigentliche schloss bindet den
sogenannten hc 2 rezeptor um dann in die
zelle einzudringen
diese antikörper blockieren praktisch
den schlüssel des virus um in die zelle
einzudringen und damit den organismus zu
infizieren und für welche patienten ist
dieses medikament dann gedacht
die komplikation die wir haben ist dass
dieses medikament in europa gar nicht
zugelassen ist und so gesehen kann ich
ihnen auch nicht sagen wie die
indikation für europa aussieht aber für
amerika die dieses präparat hat in
amerika eine
die zulassung ist dieses präparat
gedacht für leichte kost 19 fälle von
patienten die nicht hospitalisiert sind
und auch noch nicht beatmet werden
also es wird sehr früh gegeben es kann
nur sehr früh gegeben werden denn es
soll ja die infektion verhindern da
spielt es ganz eine wichtige rolle dass
das medikament dann gegeben werden wenn
auch noch viren da sind also bei den
schweren kobe 19 fällen da ist oft gar
kein virus mehr da die werden verursacht
durch unser eigenes immunsystem und da
nützt es überhaupt nichts dieses
medikament zu ihm ziehen
aber können sie noch etwas zu der
wirkung sagen wie gut wirkt das denn aus
ihrer sicht das ist schwer zu sagen weil
die wahl weil noch wenig bekannt ist man
weiß dass das medikament ist getestet
und es ist allerdings die ergebnisse
waren nicht so gut dass man sagen würde
okay wir lassen das unbedingt zu es
verkürzt ein klein wenig die
krankheitsdauer wenn es an schlecht wenn
man es zum richtigen zeitpunkt gibt aber
es ist jetzt nicht ein ein
sensationelles medikament obwohl die
theorie die dahintersteckt extrem
plausibel ist aber das ist nicht selten
dass solche theorien plausibel sind die
sich dann in der klinik aber nicht so
abbilden lassen wir wollen das
eigentlich erwartet hätte
und wie sollte das medikament an
verteilt werden wer sollte es bekommen
ihrer meinung nach
das ist eine schwierige frage so weit
ich weiß ist dieses medikament jetzt an
unikliniken verschickt worden zu
spezialisten das halte ich auch für
richtig dass die hier solange die
spezialisten dieses medikament
applizieren sollten aber die patienten
die hier in frage kommen
die liegen ja gar nicht in den kliniken
das ist ja ausdrücklich gesagt für noch
nicht hospitalisierten patienten
meines erachtens nach gehört dieses
medikament wenn man es denn überhaupt
einsetzt was sehr problematisch ist wir
verlassen uns normalerweise darauf dass
wir eine zulassung haben in europa eine
europäische zulassung durch die emea
dieses medikament sollte meines
erachtens in pflegeeinrichtungen in
altersheimen usw eingesetzt werden dort
kann man sehr eng beobachten ob eine
patientin ein patient erkrankt und dann
diesen alten menschen die natürlich auch
zu den risikopatienten gehören diesen
alten menschen dann dieses medikament
injiziert
danke schön herr dingermann für ihre
fachliche einschätzung vielen dank und
damit gebe ich jetzt zurück zu euch
[Musik]
nicky war 16 und nikki hatte keine
chance
ja das sagte die mutter von nicole
scharrer heute vor gerichten die kölner
die vor 27 jahren auf dem heimweg
ermordet wurde
heute hat die mutter dem mörder ihrer
tochter vor gericht in die augen blicken
müssen erklärungen bekamen sie keine
aber ein urteil endlich gerechtigkeit
fast 10.000 tage muss das ehepaar
schalla warten bis der mörder ihrer
tochter verurteilt wird
ralph haase lebenslänglich hinter gitter
ganze 27 jahre nach dem mord an nicole
scheller
es ist der vierzehnte oktober 1993
nicole kommt gerade von ihrem freund und
steigt gegen 22 uhr aus dem bus der
linie 462 aus sie ist auf dem weg nach
hause doch da kommt nicole nie an
die staatsanwaltschaft geht davon aus
dass sie ein man folgt nur 30 meter von
der bushaltestelle entfernt kommt es
dann zu der schrecklichen tat
nicole wird brutal ermordet er wirkt
erschreckend ist dass nicole laut
obduktion fünf bis acht minuten um ihr
leben gekämpft hat bevor sie ohnmächtig
wurde
es findet keine vergewaltigung statt
doch der täter und lösten die kurzen
team bereich und zerreißt ihren slip in
diekholzen team bereich wurden dna
spuren gefunden die durch neueste
technik jetzt den heute 56 jahre alten
reif hat zugeordnet werden konnten
bis zuletzt beteuerte er seine unschuld
so auch am letzten verhandlungstag fünf
tage vor dem motto urteil schrecklich
und belastend für die familie der
getöteten nicole
am selben tag erleidet sigrid schaller
einen herzinfarkt gemeinsam mit ihrem
mann hat sie alle bisherigen
verhandlungstage verfolgt die verkündung
des urteils muss joachim scheller wegen
des gesundheitlichen zustand seiner frau
nun ohne sie verfolgen
ich muss ja und dann ihn freilassen
also das ist der rechtsprechung ich weiß
gar nicht ob der vorsitzender ralf h ist
also wegen des mordes an die colts
schaller zu einer lebenslangen
haftstrafe verurteilt aber ins gefängnis
muss er zunächst trotzdem nicht das ist
meiner 30-jährigen karriere bisher das
erste mal dass jemand wegen mordes
verurteilt wird aber nach wie vor auf
freiem fuß bleibt das heißt also der
haftbefehl das ja nicht wieder in kraft
gesetzt worden
das entspricht dem was der vorsitzende
auch seinerzeit einmal erklärt hat indem
man gesagt hat durch sache wird zu
gesucht vom bundesgerichtshof
entschieden
nach dem motto reicht die dünne
indizienlage aus oder nicht es könnte
also noch monate vergehen bis das
gesprochene urteil rechtskräftig ist bis
dahin kann sich ralph h zum entsetzen
von nicoles eltern frei bewegen
[Musik]
es ist das weltgrößte sportereignis und
es findet in diesem jahr statt trotz
corona und zwar im stadion und zwar mit
publikum der super bowl das finale der
nordamerikanischen football liegen zwei
wochen ungefähr steigt das finale und
mit dabei sein werden rund 22.000
zuschauer darunter ganz viele geimpfte
krankenschwestern altenpfleger ärzte usw
was für eine emotion und als sie werden
wie hunderte millionen zuschauer vor den
bildschirm ein ganz besonderes duell
erleben
es sind bilder die auch in deutschland
hoffnung machen zuschauer im stadion
beim nfl spiel der green bay packers
gegen die tampa bay buccaneers waren
immer 9000 best gelautet fans erlaubt in
feuerten ihr team bleibt beim super bowl
in zwei wochen sind es sogar 22.000
zuschauer ein vorbild auch für
deutschland die 22.000 glücklichen
werden dann beim 55 finale und größten
sportevent der welt wieder einmal ford
wolle gerne tom brady bestaunen dürfen
der superstar der tampa bay buccaneers
sie zum zehnten mal in den superbowl ein
dem finalspiel der nfl ein einsamer
rekord in der größten football liga der
welt und auch privat läuft es für die
quarterback ikone
seit 2009 ist er mit dem brasilianischen
top-model gisele bündchen verheiratet
die beiden haben zwei gemeinsame kinder
william blake und benjamin der 43
jährige wechselte vor der saison von den
patriots zu den buccaneers ein mutiger
schritt
brady spielte 20 jahren jugend und wurde
dort zu einer lebenden legende jetzt
könnte der legenden status aber noch
weiter anwachsen in dem nfc conference
finale kam es zum duell mit den green
bay packers um deren quarterback aaron
rodgers die bucks erwischen den besseren
start brady gibt seinem ersten touchdown
pass concessions
die richtung vor die zweite halbzeit
beginnt wie die erste aufgehört hat
wieder brady mit seinem dritten
touchdown pass und das holen die packers
nicht mehr auf die batterie es können
die zeit runter spielen um gewinn das
duell mit 31 zu 26 der ewige brady hat
es wieder geschafft
[Applaus]
im super bowl steht er nun patrick mehr
holmes gegenüber der quarterback der
kansas city chiefs ist zusammen mit
brady der superstar der liga und
amtierender champion auch privat könnte
es für uns nicht besser laufen seine
verlobte brittany matthäus ist
hochschwanger und erwartet ein
töchterchen der super bowl titel wäre da
nur ein weiterer grund zum feiern
privat im siebten himmel und beruflich
den zweiten nfl titel vor der nase
besser könnte es für den texaner nicht
laufen im nfc conference finale konnten
sich die chiefs ging die bild
durchsetzen
der touchdown nach lochpass von holmes
ist der endgültige sargnagel für die
bild die tipps gewinnt ungefährdet mit
38 zu 24 und die ganze fußballwelt freut
sich auf das duell brady gegen holmes
die nfl legende gegen den 18 jahre
jüngeren amtierenden super bowl nbp das
spiel findet am 7 februar in tampa statt
heimspiel für brady und die buccaneers
kick off in deutschland ist am 8 februar
um 9 uhr 30 die sportwelt schaut auf den
superboni fußballfans die schau nach
london der fc chelsea hat einen neuen
trainer
und der ist ein alter bekannter aus der
bundesliga thomas tuchel wird neuer
trainer des fc chelsea
der 47 jährige beerbt den am
montagmittag entlassenen frank lampard
unter ihm standen die blues zuletzt nur
noch auf platz neun der premier league
zu wenig für die ansprüche der londoner
die sich im sommer massiv verstärkt
hatten unter anderem mit den beiden
deutschen nationalspielern timo werner
und covers für mehr als 130 millionen
euro
tuchel wurde erst ende letzten jahres
bei frankreichs serienmeister paris
sammer entlassen
nur einen monat später also das comeback
auf der trainerbank bereits am mittwoch
sitzt suche bei der partie gegen
wolverhampton
der chelsea bank dann soll es für den
londoner club wieder nach oben in der
tabelle
ja es klingt wie eine seifenoper
es wäre auch wirklich unterhaltsam würde
es bei dieser geschichte nur um die
liebe eines königs gehen aber es geht um
sehr viel mehr der thailändische könig
will seiner konkubine ein ganz
besonderes geschenk machen eines das
nicht nur einzigartig ist sondern auch
einfluss auf das ganze land haben wird
denn dieser teil könig der ist sagen wir
mal sehr speziell
er ist der mächtigste und reichste mann
thailands könig maha vajiralongkorn oder
kurz rama der zehnte sohn des legendären
und überaus beliebten vaters und königs
bhumibol seit 2016 herrscher über das
königreich thailand sohn drama ist beim
volk allerdings unbeliebt lebt
vorzugsweise in einem luxushotel in
garmisch partenkirchen und führt auch
sonst einen eher unkonventionellen
lebensstil in thailand regt sich schon
länger widerstand gegen den könig die
pro demokratie bewegung will rama den
zehnten vom thron stoßen die bei den
thais beliebte könig schwester siering
dorn die den konflikt mit ihrem
extrovertierten bruder nicht scheut
musste ins krankenhaus nachdem sie sich
bei einem spaziergang mit ihrem bruder
beide knöchel gebrochen hatte jetzt der
nächste skandal der die thailänder
fassungslos macht der verheiratete rama
will offenbar seine zweitfrau auch zur
königin krönen lassen als kleines
geschenk zum 36
geburtstag und obwohl bigamie also das
mehrfach verheiratet sein in thailand
wie auch in deutschland offiziell
verboten und strafbar ist doch für rama
den zehnten gottähnliche könig thailands
gelten offenbar schon länger keine
weltlichen gesetze mehr ja- und all die
exklusiven details dieser geschichte die
besprechen wir jetzt mit max böddeker
unser experte für das thailändische
königshaus hallo marx soll
wie kann das sein dass man einfach so
ein geschenk machen kann das vergeht
einem jahr auf der zunge wollen wir auch
gerne alle haben solche positionen zum
geburtstag aber wie kann er sein
wie kann das sein dass du so was machen
kommen
das kann ganz einfach weil der
thailändische könig ist weil er soeben
in der anmoderation gehört haben eben
gott gleich ist eigentlich darf es nicht
weil die biografie ist einfach verboten
in thailand seit 1935 aber erschwert
sich eben nicht um mehr macht es ganz
einfach jetzt lasst uns mal weiter über
das liebesleben des königs sprechen denn
das geht ja also könnte man sagen auf
und ab beschreiben ist einmal die
protagonisten also wir brauchen die
königin wir brauchen die geliebte und
wir brauchen die beziehung zwischen den
beteiligten personen wird also ich
versuche mir ganz knapp zu machen es
wäre zum einen könig maha vajiralongkorn
der ein bisschen extrovertiert drücken
wir es mal so ist ist er ganz einfach
und dann haben wir königin zu tiger die
am 19 mai 2009 10 ge licht hat
gleichzeitig hatte er aber damals schon
seine geliebte koi also lieber früher
krankenschwester und was in seinem harem
dann ist sie befördert worden so
generalmajor ihnen also ganz ganz
schnell dann zur zweitfrau und die wird
eben jetzt dann wenn für könig alles gut
geht die zwei königin auch und wir haben
aber noch eine weitere person das ist
prinzessin sirion korn
das ist die schwester des königs und die
spieler wie ganz ganz bedeutende rolle
dabei die ist nämlich gegen diese
beziehung beziehungsweise gegen diese
beförderung vom co und koi und der könig
haben sich ja auch ein paar nachrichten
geschrieben die du uns auch exklusiv
mitgebracht hast ja was genau ist dort
in diesen nachrichten ausgetauscht
worden
ausgeschafft worden sind einfach eine
eher liebeserklärungen sagen wir mal so
in zahlen form also sie hat zum beispiel
ein foto wir sehen es auch gerade
gemacht beziehungsweise collage da steht
halt 1904 904 ist der der deckname des
königs wenn irgendwo öffentlich
unterwegs ist und bei ihr zum beispiel 0
11 0 11 ist der ja die position im harem
des königs er hat sie alle
durchnummeriert damit dass ich da noch
nicht alle namen merken müssen muss als
keine ahnung
und das hat sie ihm also geschickt und
einiges mehr
und jetzt beschreiben uns einmal was
bedeutet das denn für das thailändische
volk werden das jetzt besprochen als sei
es eine seifenoper sich das eingangs ja
auch gesagt aber letztendlich was
bedeutet der könig und auch
seine entscheidungen die er jetzt trifft
für das thailändische volk das
thailändische volk ist natürlich nicht
besonders amüsiert mit der ganzen
geschichte
ich habe im prinzessin sie lincoln schon
erwähnt die wird im land auch app
genannt heißt so viel wie eine
prinzessin ist im land sehr sehr beliebt
und er soll sie ja vergangene woche soll
eine auseinandersetzung mit ihr gehabt
haben und im zuge dieser
auseinandersetzung soll sich schwer
verletzt haben nach außen wurde so
dargestellt dass sie beim spazierengehen
mit beiden beinen gleichzeitig
umgeknickt um geknackt ist weiß nicht du
als frau kannst du vielleicht die
wahrscheinlichkeit besser einschätzen
könnte auch mit einem passieren irgendwo
erholen hatten aber in wirklichkeit
basel hatte die auseinandersetzung mit
ihr und ist ja sagen wir mal so sein
barangebot gegangen die wurde daneben
operiert und ist jetzt im rollstuhl und
wird monatelang nicht laufen können
das spricht sich natürlich im
thailändischen bevölkerung rum und führt
dazu dass jetzt eben diese anti
monarchie bewegung wieder auflodert und
auf land und das könnte dann im
zweifelsfall für den könig in ganz ganz
böses oder bitteres ende nehmen also
zumal er sich ja auch über geltendes
teilen das ist recht einfach
hinweggesetzt
er ist eben der omnipotente wonach der
tut und macht was er will und das bevor
die anti monarchie bewegungen thailand
kann er das denn so einfach sich über
dieses recht hinwegsetzen oder befürchte
dass du dass das jetzt in den kommenden
tagen irgendwie in irgendeiner form
konsequenzen haben könnte er kann das
auf alle fälle machen wie gesagt er hat
ja kein regularium um sich herum also ja
er macht einfach weil es kann aber es
könnte ja auch konsequenzen haben wenn
er wieder nach deutschland zurück
hoffentlich vergessen ist jetzt so lange
zeit in thailand das war aber noch nie
so lange in thailand und er will
irgendwann wieder nach deutschland
zurück und auch nach deutschem recht ist
die bgi verboten wenn er zurückkommt
muss es hier und deutsches recht halten
und er kann sich nicht darauf berufen er
hat es sind diplomatenpass er reist ja
laut thailändischer auffassung eben als
privatperson und das könnte auch für ihn
probleme in deutschland an geben
letztendlich eine unglaubliche
geschichte der thailändische könig macht
seine geliebte zum geburtstag zur
königin und das alles auf
es hat unser kollege max böddeker vielen
herzlichen dank für deinen besuch hier
im studio gehört dass immer wieder neue
bizarre news aus diesem land in dem
nicht corona zeiten so viele von uns
sonst urlaub machen damit verabschieden
wir uns patricia für heute und sehen uns
einfach morgen wieder wir sehen uns ein
paar sachen wenn sie mögen wir freuen
uns schönen abend
[Musik]